[موسيقى]
في عام 2019
مع منتجه في متناول اليد ،
كان سكاي كورتز يتنقل في طريقه حول أحد
أكبر المعارض التجارية في دبي ،
صباح الخير يا
إلهي ، هذا يبدو وكأنه رفع إلى الأبد
صورة شركته
الحصاد النقي ، وهي واحدة من أولى
المزارع المائية في الوسط  شرق
مرحبًا معي بالمتحدث التالي ، كان
الحصاد الخالص حدثًا مثيرًا للغاية
كان يتعلق بالتمويل ولكن أيضًا
حول
التعاون حول التواصل مع
الناس والدخول في حوار حول
ريادة الأعمال والنظام البيئي هنا
في الإمارات العربية
المتحدة وحول التكنولوجيا التي
تستوردها الإمارات العربية المتحدة  حوالي 80 في المائة من
طعامها ،
لذلك عندما تعطلت سلاسل التوريد التقليدية
بسبب الوباء ،
بدأت الأعمال التجارية في الازدهار عند الحصاد الخالص ،
لذلك بطريقة غريبة ، كانت كوبنهاغن
حدثًا للتوعية بأهمية
شركات مثل شركتنا التي تعرف أنها
تساهم في الإنتاج المحلي
للأغذية
تعلن جميع دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
عن مبادرات وتمويل
لدعم الإنتاج الغذائي المحلي
.  SA إنه وقت مهم بالنسبة لنا الآن ، فقد
أدى حدث توعوي تحول إلى
صفقة ضخمة لشركة Sky الناشئة
في أبريل من هذا العام في ذروة
موسم الحصاد الصافي للوباء ، إلى ضمان التزام استثماري
بقيمة مائة مليون
دولار
باعتباره أكبر
صفقة في مجال التكنولوجيا الزراعية على الإطلاق في المنطقة
ليس الأمر كما اعتقدت أنه
سيحدث إذا كنت صادقًا ، فنحن أحد
الأطراف التي كانت محظوظة في
هذا الموقف ، لقد كان هذا في الواقع بمثابة
نعمة لصناعتنا ، ولدينا القليل من
مهارات النجاة حول ذلك